[Musique]
bonsoir seller d'auditions publiques le
rendez vous du lundi soir en direct
pendant une heure sur lcp assemblée
nationale public sénat avec le figaro
live c'est l'heure de faire le point sur
les grands dossiers du moment
l'actualité chaude aussi avec un invité
qu'on reçoit pendant une heure et avec
vos questions aussi que vous pouvez nous
envoyer sur figaro live et que je
transmettrai à l'invité qui est ce soir
nicole belloubet bonsoir vous êtes mise
la justice garde des sceaux une toute
première question parce qu'on va
beaucoup parler ce soir évidemment
puisque vous êtes une des premières à
réagir notamment sur les mesures qui ont
été annoncées aujourd'hui pour lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
notamment les violences conjugales au
sens large il y un terme qui revient
souvent c'est le mot féminicide en
termes juridiques ça n'existe pas est-ce
que vous souhaiteriez vous qu'il soit
reconnue officiellement
alors je ne suis pas nécessairement
favorable à cette reconnaissance dans le
code pénal pour autant j'utilise
extrêmement fréquemment ce terme dans le
langage courant
je pense qu'il symbolise quelque chose
de précis et de que son utilisation est
tout à fait souhaitable et pourquoi
cadre bien parce que dans le code pénal
d'une part on ne distingue pas les
meurtre sur enfant sur hommes / femmes
en revanche il est précisé que le
meurtre sur conjoint quel que soit le
conjoint à une est une circonstance
aggravante
donc il me semble que cette globalité de
prise en compte du meurtre sur conjoint
et d'égalité et déjà dans le code pénal
donc vraiment si vous voulez je trouve
que dans le langage familier c'est très
bien je ne suis pas nécessairement
convaincu de son 1 de son utilisation
dans le code pénal je crois que les
parlementaires doivent se saisir d'une
réflexion à ce sujet donc quand les
écuries temps on les écoutera avec des
gâteries sur presque à faire des
propositions sur ce sujet là je crois
qu'ils doivent s'en saisir et n'ont fait
part donc je suivrai avec intérêt on va
cueillir mano thème traduit de public
sénat hybride bouchée de lcp assemblée
nationale sur ce plateau
à
[Musique]
jordan bonsoir brigitte ans avec nous ce
serait plateau comme tous les ans
d'histoire et bien évidemment on va
commencer évidemment par toutes les
annonces autour des violences conjugales
qui ont été faites aujourd'hui brigitte
oui les associations de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes réclamé un
milliard d'euros le haut conseil à
l'égalité et disait qu'il fallait entre
500 millions et 1 milliard d'euros
or vous n'avez mis sur la table que 360
millions d'euros
on est loin du compte je ne crois pas
qu'on soit loin du compte parce que
d'abord le comme l'a dit le premier
ministre il y à bien un milliard d'euros
sur les questions d'égalité homme femme
sur plusieurs années et 360 vous l'avais
dit à l'instant sur la question
spécifique des violences conjugales
c'est une somme importante je crois
qu'au delà de ces sommes financières qui
évidemment doivent être prises en compte
il y a aussi un investissement de
différents ministères pour changer la
réalité des choses est de mon point de
vue ce changement-là changement de
procédure changement d'attitude
changements dans les coûts de changement
les solutions
il est important qu'elle alain financier
je ne dirais pas plus important mais en
tout cas tout aussi important est la
vérité de se fera là dont georges
maintenant thème par thème ya deux trois
propositions qu'on a retenu exactement
sur les mesures concrètes à propos du
secret médical
edouard philippe soit complice qu'on
puisse y déroger dans des cas très
encadrée d'urgence absolue
on va pouvoir et pas de voir si les
médecins n'ont pas d'obligation qui est
ce que ça va bien pouvoir concernés ça
va concerner très peu de monde
non je pense que c'est une latitude qui
est donnée à des médecins de pouvoir
faire des signalements
c'est très important parce qu'il voit
parfois des situations de souffrance
dramatique et évidemment ils sont liés
par ce secret professionnel il faut en
même temps être très prudent et c'est la
raison pour laquelle un travail est
actuellement conduits avec le conseil de
l'ordre des médecins maccoll la gagne
est plus ainsi lâché les réserves
d'edouard philippe c'est aussi plan cela
gronde à énoncer pas des réserves si
voulez quand vous allez voir un médecin
il faut que vous puissiez avoir
totalement confiance en lui donc dans le
secret professionnel pour pouvoir lui
livrer ce que vous avez à lui dire en
même temps quand il ya des femmes qui
sont dans des situations de danger
extrême
il est tout à fait logique que le
médecin puisse être déliés de ce secret
là lorsqu'il ya vraiment un
parce que je pense qu'ils le feront je
pense qu'ils le feront voyez vous j'ai
entendu des médecins parler dialoguer
entre eux et il y en a pour lesquelles
ça semblait naturel donc je crois qu'ils
le feront je crois là encore que l'
équilibre entre le secret professionnel
et l'urgence il se trouvera naturels
d'origine il a le souci de force et qui
sera reconnu comme une circonstance
aggravante et une forme de harcèlement
conjugal finalement sur korriban ou
suicide oui sur quoi on va se baser
finalement pour définir la notion
d'emprise alors d'abord l'emprise de
faire son apparition la cette fois ci
dans le texte de loi ce qui est
évidemment un point important puisque la
recherche a progressé sur ces phénomènes
de violence conjugale et qu'on
s'aperçoit que l'emprise qui est une
forme de finalement de les femmes sont
liés par par des éléments de pressions
psychologiques auxquels ils peuvent vous
avez toutes sortes d'éléments c'est un
faisceau d'indicés a fait son travail
c'est compliqué toujours de déterminer
oui mais les causes on ne se suicide pas
du jour au lendemain dans ces
circonstances là il y a donc une vie
antérieure il y a des éléments soient de
pression morale de pressions
psychologiques des sms qui sont envoyées
d une surveillance qui est le fait de
voir l'état se devra être établie
évidemment par l' enquête
autre mesure contenue dans le plan la
suppression de l'autorité parentale
ça aura pour asus la suspension de
l'autorité parentale qui pourra
intervenir à la mise en examen du
conjoint ou lorsqu à une tentative
d'homicide
est ce que ce n'est pas trop tard à quel
stade faut-il déclenché cette suspension
d'autorité parentale
alors d'abord elle ça pourrait être fait
vous le disiez del'enquête ensuite je
crois que ce qui est important c'est de
porter remède à des situations absurdes
je connais des cas des parents de
victimes qui viennent me voir en disant
que l'auteur les empêche de s'occuper de
leurs petits enfants de façon normale
naturelle et simple
ça n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
possible et c'est la raison pour
laquelle quand il ya eu homicide
la suspension de l'autorité parentale
sera depuis un endroit non revanche ce
qu'elle dit est d'aider la mise en
examen mais est-ce que ça devrait pas
être dès le premier coup alors il faut
tout de même qu'il y est
des éléments qui puissent être
rassemblés pour pouvoir prouver qu'il y
a une difficulté est donc là ce sera
évidemment le travail du juge
ils ont l'habitude de faire cela est-ce
que des consignes ont été passées où
sont passés au procureur pour que
justement la chaîne se gérer leur
efficace il y a deux choses d'abord deux
choses d'abord le 9 mai dernier
j'ai adressé une circulaire à tous les
procureurs généraux et procureur de la
république qui porte sur la question du
traitement des violences conjugales
c'est une circulaire spécifique sur cet
objet là en requérant leur attention en
développant un certain nombre de points
d'une part d'autre part après que les
textes de loi soit adopté puisqu'il ya
un texte actuellement en cours de
discussion au parlement et un autre qui
viendra dans quelque temps je vais
réunir au mois de janvier
l'ensemble des procureurs pour évoquer
avec eux ce sujet là je dois dire que
healy a d'ores et déjà au moment où je
vous parle beaucoup d'initiatives qui
sont prises en différents parquets et
qui sont tout à fait remarquables
il faut maintenant que nous aboutissions
à la généralisation parce que ce qui
fait la force
vraiment de la lutte contre ces
violences conjugales c'est qu'il n'y ait
aucune faille aucun interstices du
travail le syndicat de la magistrature
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas
franchement je ne vois que de la volonté
mais il faut qu'il y ait des processus
des procédures qui se met en place pour
que entre le parquet le juge aux
affaires familiales le juge des enfants
il puisse y avoir vraiment un échange
d'informations justement pourquoi ne pas
aller plus loin
aller jusqu'à des tribunaux spécialisés
en violence conjugale
c'est ce qui existe en espagne heures
même bientôt des juges dont ce sera
vraiment la spécialité qui auront étudié
c'est ce que nous souhaitons faire non
pas maintenant maintenant c'est ce que
nous souhaitons animer sur chamakh
strict je m'explique non c'est au bas
des tribunaux spécifique mais ce seront
des filières de l'urgence qui seront
spécialisés dans ce traitement de
l'urgence spécifiques comme en avait
mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'il y ait un
modèle unique vous évoquez le modèle
espagnol qui d'ailleurs a mis des années
à se mettre en place
moi je vous dis que ce qui fonctionne
remarquablement par exemple j'étais tout
à l'heure avec le président de la
république qui à moins d'une heure au
tribunal de créteil et bien dans ce
tribunal là il y a des
ir spécifique de traitement des
violences conjugales
et cela fonctionne remarquablement cela
existe ailleurs je cite créteil ça
existe ailleurs mais nous voulons en
quelque sorte nous adapter à chaque
tribunal parce que dans 5 grandes
juridictions comme à créteil
vous pouvez avoir des chambres qui
traite spécifiquement de ces sujets là
mais dans un petit tribunal où vous avez
un nombre limité de magistrats ne peut
pas faire des chambres spécifique il
faut des procédures spécifiques des
procédures urgentes c'est cela qu'ils
sont faits l'un plus que l'autre ni non
pas du groupe nc n'a rien à voir avec
les moyens non je dis donc on est juge
assez juste doute pas mais parce que
quand vous allez dans une petite ville
de province vous n'avez pas le même
nombre de juges qu'elle voudrait nous
imposer c'est pas une question de moyens
c'est une question d'adaptation à la
situation est donc ce que lorsque je
suis en train de dire c'est qu'il faut
des procédures adaptées à chaque type de
tribunal jsk une proposition de loi en
janvier y aura une visiblement est ce
que vous espérez un consensus politique
finalement comme pour la proposition la
d'aurélien pradié sur d'éloignement
écoutez oui moi je souhaite que sur ces
sujets xao cible je pense que c'est
possible parce que j'ai des critiques
quand même peut-être notamment
politiques sur sur le manque de moyens
les dogues ont mimé les dispositions
législatives dont nous parlons elle ne
porte pas sur le manque de moyens
pardon sur les moyens qu elle porte sur
les procédures elle porte sur
l'assouplissement sur l'autorité
parentale sur l' ordonnance de
protection sur le bracelet anti
rapprochement ça ne porte pas sur les
moyens les moyens ça relève d'autres
dispositions votées à l'unanimité
vous demandez si c'est possible donc je
ne vois pas si vous voulez alors il peut
y avoir des désaccords technique sur tel
ou tel point
mais je ne vois pas comment on peut
s'opposer à ce type de mesures qui ont
été proposées
alors il ya une autre réforme dont on
parle de gîtes et on voudrait savoir si
verra le jour
c'est la réforme de la magistrature qui
datent de 2,58
c'est une information du journal le
monde est-ce que vous travaillez à une
réforme de ce genre alors que je suis un
peu prématuré de dire que nous y
travaillons puisque enfin non nous y
réfléchissons c'est prématuré de dire
que la réforme est tabou dit pas ce
qu'il y'a aucun arbitrage que je n'ai
aucune proposition
fi nit iv est stable mais oui il y à des
évolutions sur lesquels nous sommes en
train de réfléchir qui sont liées par
exemple à la question de la formation
puisque vous savez qu'il ya actuellement
une mission
porté par monsieur thiriez qui réfléchit
à la formation donc il faut réfléchir à
cela
il ya également des questions qui
peuvent se poser sur la durée de deux
magistrales la durée durant laquelle un
magistrat reste dans un post je trouve
qu'il ya un tournoi interne ou externe
il ya des réflexions mais c'est naturel
et d'ailleurs je l'avais dis moi même
lorsque j'ai présenté la grande loi de
réforme de la justice
est-ce que vous réfléchissez au fait de
renforcer la possibilité de déclencher
des mesures disciplinaires c'est à dire
de pouvoir porter plainte selon
comprenant un juge d écouter c'est une
question qui effectivement est posée de
manière récurrente
il y actuellement des possibilités de
déclencher une procédure disciplinaire à
l'encontre d'un magistrat
lorsque les particuliers saisissent le
conseil de la magistrature
il est effectivement assez peu fréquent
qui est le pouvoir disciplinaire ne
m'appartient pas n'est ce pas moi je
peux éventuellement déclencher mais le
pouvoir discuter ne m'appartient pas
celle appartient au conseil supérieur de
la magistrature pour pour faire court et
donc si vous voulez c'est vrai qu'à
l'heure actuelle les possibilités
d'enclenchement sont passés au précédent
mais moins c'est un point sur lequel on
peut réfléchir
est ce qu'il y aura donc juste pour une
question très clair est ce qu'il y aura
un call est ce qu'il y ait un calendrier
pour la fin des temps je suis désolé de
ne pas vous donner une réponse ferme là
parce que comme vous le savez il ya
beaucoup de réformes qui sont en cours
actuellement je pense à la réforme des
retraites je pense que nous allons
parler des lois sur les violences
conjugales je pourrais citer d'autres
exemples qui sont déjà
donc ceci n'est pas à l'ordre du jour
pour l'instant dans un calendrier
parlementaire disons que le calendrier
parlementaire n'est pas arrêté si je
peux le faire je le ferai volontiers
c'est pas sûr non il ya une réforme
constitutionnelle qui semble un peu
embourbé est-ce que vous souhaitiez que
cette réforme de la magistrature
l'indépendance du parquet elle puisse
figurer dans une réforme je suis
institutionnels quoi qu'il arrive même
si
profonde et il pourrait y avoir une
réforme peut pour cette question je sois
l'indépendance au parquet par exemple si
vous voulez je pense d'une part qu'il le
faudrait parce que cela répond à des
préoccupations permanentes
cela permettrait peut-être aussi
d'atténuer ou d'atténuer les soupçons
qui pèsent ici et là sur l'indépendance
du parquet encore que ces soupçons n'ont
pas lieu d'être mais enfin peu importe
en tout cas c'est une promesse qui a été
faite depuis longtemps et par plusieurs
majorités
les textes sont prêts nous sommes il ya
à peu près un consensus sur ce sujet là
et donc c'est une promesse sur laquelle
moi je me suis engagé et président de la
république préfère actuellement vous le
savez il y a un projet de réforme
conscio neil qui a été déposée le
gouvernement doit passer en conseil des
ministres et donc ce projet existe
j'espère qu'il pourra voir le jour pour
compléter ce que disait gide ou fort
pour reprendre ce que vous disiez s qui
pour y avait une réforme
constitutionnelle seulement sur ce que
l'on met tout est possible tout est
possible vous apportez vous le demander
ce soir je voudrais qu'il y ait une
réforme constitutionnelle dans le global
global est en tout cas je suis entend
garder sow très attachés de ces
évolutions sur le statut du parquet on
va parler des gilet jaune qui ont
affaire avec la justice table et pas
forcément mais les forces de l'ordre les
forces de l'ordre puisque jeudi à paris
trois mois de prison avec sursis ont été
requis contre un crs qui avait jeté un
pavé vers des manifestants et puis au
total il ya près de 400 procédure pour
violences qui ont été lancées à
l'encontre des membres des forces de
l'ordre mais quasiment rien n'aboutit
comment se l'expliquer est ce que c'est
normal
alors moi ce que je voudrais dire c'est
que nous sommes en france dans un état
de droit et que dans cet état de droit
évidemment les policiers peuvent
utiliser la force de manière
proportionnée et de manière évidemment
circonstances il sait ce qu'il veut
c'est non justement puisqu'il ya une
condamnation
donc ils doivent utiliser la force je
disais de manière proportionnée et
adaptée
c'est ce qu'il faut et vous savez dans
quelles conditions difficiles ils ont
joué le rôle qu'ils ont tu toute l'année
dernière
nous sommes dans un état de droit donc
toute utilisation non proportionnée sera
évidemment soumises à une enquête à une
information judiciaire et fera l'objet
le cas échéant d'une sanction pourquoi
est ce que cela prend du temps
tout simplement parce qu'il y a des
informations judiciaires qui sont en
cours que cela est long encore une fois
parce qu'il faut dans l'utilisation de
la force démêler ce qui relève de
l'utilisation normale et d'une
utilisation disproportionnée line adapté
et donc 16 ans ces informations
judiciaires sont longues
elles aboutiront pas deux poids deux
mesures comme non si madame anne faisant
je comprends qu'il puisse le dire mais
ce n'est pas deux poids deux mesures et
cette comparution immédiate pour les
forces de l'ordre
je viens de vous dire c'est ça pourrait
devenir sa next door mais oui mais parce
que si vous voulez nous sommes dans deux
situations différentes
d'un côté vous avez des policiers qui
ont pour tâche le maintien de l'ordre
public qui doit-on prendre les mesures
adaptées
de l'autre vous avez parfois des
manifestants qui utilisent la violence
parfois pas tous fly tous je fais je
fais bien la distinction et donc il est
normal que dans ces situations là il y
ait des appréciations qui soit plus
complexe dans un cadre dans ce cas d'
enquête s'est confiée à l'igpn la police
judiciaire oui mais il ya quand même du
gpn est ce que c'est un gage de
transparence
bah écoutez ce sont des autorités ce
sont des institutions indépendantes
l'inspection générale de la justice est
indépendante également deux mois et
fournit des rapports vous l'avez vu sur
les violences conjugales le rapport qui
a été remis récemment sur les cas de
féminicide d'il ya deux ou trois ans
c'est un rapport qui est quand même
assez dur pour la justice et bien c'est
pareil pour la police oui je crois
l'indépendance des inspections bien sûr
on est par ailleurs il y à une
information judiciaire qui suivent
question puisqu'on parle des sujets
d'actualité il y a les retraites aussi
dont on va par l'état effectivement le
gouvernement qui est convoqué pour une
grande réunion à ce week-end pour
montrer et bien qu'ils se mobilisent
parce que c'est une mise en scène pour
montrer que vous ne céderez pas sur la
question des retraites
pas du tout s'il s'agit alors ce n'est
pas une maison
scène puisque vous êtes fine
journalistes vous avez observé que nous
sommes nous avons régulièrement des
séminaires gouvernementaux généralement
ils sont dimanche d'ailleurs parce que
c'est le seul moment où on peut
travailler dans le calme dans une par
rapport à des semaines qu'ils sont très
chargées donc bref nous avons dimanche
un séminaire gouvernemental qui sera
évidemment consacrée pour partie en tout
cas la réforme des retraites c'est pas
du tout une mise en scène cela aussi est
convoquée dans l'urgence quand même mais
pas du tout pas du tout non merci pas
franchement les similaire
gouvernementaux on les connaît on les
convoque pas des mois al avance et par
ailleurs nous sommes prévenus déjà
depuis une semaine il était donc cms est
urgent que tout à l'heure c'est pour ça
qu'on se dit tiens les ministres peuvent
être informé avant les avocats vont se
mobiliser le 5 décembre pour la grève
des retraites
est ce que les avocats sont des
corporatistes comme les comme le
cheminot par exemple disons que les
avocats sont dans une situation
particulière puisqu'ils ont un régime
autonome actuellement et que ce régime
autonome il envisage comme pouvant
fonctionner dans la durée ce n'est pas
l'analyse qu'a fait le conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui pensent
que la démographie du de la profession d
avocat ne permettra pas au bout d'un
certain moment de continuer à avoir un
régime équilibré et donc nous il nous
semble intéressant qu'il puisse
rejoindre le régime universel qui est
proposé la double et leurs cotisations
non pas du tout ça c'est une ce qui a
été véhiculé par les avocats que j'ai
reçus avec jean paul delevoye à deux
reprises et nous avons échangé des
informations ne sommes pas entrés dans
une négociation je tiens à le dire ici
puisqu'il ne le souhaitait pas mais en
tout cas nous avons informé nous avons
échangé des informations de réflexion en
cours at ease de la peur des avocats je
vous le dis ils ont un régime autonome
et des styles pour l'espace qu'on dise à
des cheminots est ce qu'on pourrait dire
la même chose des avocats je vous
réponds chacun si l'on travaille je vous
dis que ils ont un régime autonome qu'il
souhaite voir perdurer morange milo
peut-être comme les cheminots
sauf que chez nous nous fixons un régime
spécial là ils ont attendu au tournant
vous les mettez pas dans la même
catégorie régime spécial et les tonneaux
et ce n'est pas la même chose on
effectivement et donc vous faites la
différence de traitement entre les
avocats les cheminots non mais si vous
allez en faire maintenir et illzach ils
ont un réflexe corporatiste ne vous le
dirais pas d'accord qu'ils ont un régime
autonome qui ne veulent pas rentrer dans
le régime universel
moi je trouve ça regrettable vraiment
parce que je trouve un peu difficile de
comprendre pourquoi on ne veut pas
rentrer dans un régime universel surtout
à partir du moment où nous leur faisons
des propositions de négociation d'une
phase de transition qui pourrait être
long il va falloir les revoir alors les
syndicats de méchoui dit je lis je les
ai mangés la fois il va falloir les
nazis déjà revu je les ai déjà vus deux
fois je suis prêt à les prêtes à les
revoir autant de fois pc cet homme en
tout cas le 5 décembre et bien ça dans
une grande journée de grève à ce que
vous êtes favorable à la proposition de
bruno retailleau qui veut instaurer un
droit au transport public garanti avec
des réquisition de grévistes
qu'est ce que vous en pensez écoutez il
y a déjà un service minimum qui est
garanti je ne suis pas favorable dans ce
stade aller au delà en revanche moi
j'appelle vraiment les gens qui veulent
manifester dont je respecte pleinement
le droit à manifester à ne pas sombrer
dans la violence c'est un risque qui
peut exister ou vous savez que dans les
manifestations il ya toujours des ultras
je crois qu'il faut veiller à cela est
ce ce que vous demandez tram est ce que
ce serait constitutionnel alors je suis
pas sûre par ailleurs mais j'ai pas lu
la proposition d'ailleurs même pas s'il
l'a écrite monsieur retailleau il y
avait un projet qui fait d'accord
c'est quoi cette société politique ses
propos laissent penser que ce n'est pas
forcément constitutionnelle aussi
apprendre sur vous ce serait après ça
sera voté parce que ça arrivera après le
5 décembre c'est bien entendu vous n'est
ce pas sûr ce serait constitution je
suis pas sûr parce que il ya une
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
sur ce type de réquisition je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit constitutionnel
effectivement une dernière question
posée une question sur romane polanski
est ce que vous trouvez qu'il doit être
extradé qu'il aurait dû être extradé par
la france puisqu'il est condamné aux
états unis on sait bien pour viol etc en
fait y'a pas de prescription la barre
oui écouter à ma connaissance alors je
me trompe peut-être parce que je n'ai
pas regardé cet aspect là des choses je
ne sais pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
y est une demande d'extradition précise
donc il faudrait que je vérifie ces
choses là en tout cas moi je le dis
clairement polanski je ne porte pas de
jugement humain sur ce qu'il a fait ou
ce qu'il est supposé avoir fait en tout
cas c'est un créateur qui est tout à
fait remarquable
je trouve qu'il faut aussi savoir
dissocier les deux une dernière question
pour boucler la boucle 1 sur les
violences sexuelles ou sexistes malin de
chapa avait dit qu'elle avait un souhait
de voir expulser les étrangers condamnés
pour violences sexistes ou sexuelles est
ce que vous vous la suivez
sachant que tu as tu diras était à blood
applaudit aussi par le rassemblement
national oui non je ne suis je ne suis
pas le souhait de cette mesure parce
qu'il existe déjà la possibilité de
prononcer une peine complémentaire de la
nature de ce que vous dites que cette
peine complémentaire dont peut-être
prononcer mais elle est laissée à
l'appréciation des juges et c'est tout à
fait indispensable en temps de paix dans
notre état de droit s'est appliqué je
suis en train de faire rechercher
précisément le nombre de cas
d'application que nous avons répondu non
pas pour répondre à marlène je comprends
qu'elle ait pu dire cela mais ce n'est
pas ma position je n'ai pas ma position
c'est à dire que sur ce sujet là je
réponds un la mesure existe des gens à
titre de peine complémentaire
elle n'est pas automatique et c'est ce
qui caractérise une mesure
juridictionnelle on va libérer tam et
brigitte jusqu'à la semaine prochaine
si mais reçoit la prochaine dans
l'édition publique lorsque nicole
belloubet maintenant vous allez avoir en
face de vous pendant une bonne vingtaine
de minutes deux parlementaires sont
réjouis qu'il y aura d'autres questions
que les celles des journalistes vous
allez vous merci
[Musique]
les des questions parlementaires qui
sont aussi d'autres questions de
réformes qui sont dans l'air du temps ou
de ou de débats alors vous avez en face
de vous il faut bernalicis bonsoir vous
êtes des réformes la france un sou lice
du nord et jérôme bascher bonsoir soir
un sénateur les républicains de l'oise
ses compères de liste qui va commencer
il voudrait vous interroger sur
l'ordonnancé de 1945 sur la justice des
mineurs
oui il a fait un colloque voilà vous
suivait parfaitement mes travaux madame
la ministre
notons que je suis des vôtres et
effectivement vous avez déposé une
ordonnance mettant sur pied un code de
la justice pénale des mineurs qui
d'ailleurs normalement rentrer en
application en octobre 2020 et il est
prévu un débat de ratification au
printemps prochain à l'assemblée et au
sénat j'ai exactement
néanmoins depuis que il ya eu cette
discussion il ya plus de débat en ce
moment qui est le groupe de contact que
vous aviez monté avec les parlementaires
n'existe plus d'ailleurs je n'en faisais
pas partie non puisque c'est elle qui a
refusé d'en faire exactement j'ai refusé
j'ai souhaité que le débat ait lieu
normalement dans des conditions normales
à l'assemblée nationale c'est parce
qu'il n'est pas l'autre mais si le
député mais je crois que si finalement
puisque le débat sur une loi de
ratification fin sur une ordonnance est
quand même un truc pour que soit brûlée
normal la question est avec ce texte
tous avaient avec ce texte on va vers
quelque chose de beaucoup plus répressif
avec potentiellement plus d'enfermement
alors comment faire mais déjà beaucoup
de mineurs en france on est un des pays
européens qui enferme le plus soin
incarcération ou dans les centres
éducatifs fermés et je pense que vous
ratez là une occasion c'est pas tout le
temps qu'on peut réformer la justice des
mineurs de faire justement une réforme
de la justice des enfants
d'ailleurs on a des juges des enfants on
n'a pas des juges des mineurs de
questions la question c'est est ce que
vous ne pensez pas que votre choix va
aller vers plus de paix n'allait plus de
répressif
là où on aurait dû faire une réforme
pénale et civile englobant l'intégralité
de la justice des enfants et que
finalement vous vous restreignez en plus
par le manque de moyens à une
une pure et simple gestion de flux avec
vos histoires de dossier unique qui vont
la suivre le jeune le mineur selon selon
le terme ce que dit monsieur le député
juste pour préciser pour les
téléspectateurs c'est qu'effectivement
les juges des enfants en france ont une
double casquette à la fois ils ont une
casquette civile qui va permettre le
placement d'un jeune à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance d'un jeune qui est en danger
et d'autre part ils ont une casquette
pénale qui va leur permettre de juger un
jeune qui a commis un acte de
délinquance dans la réforme de
l'ordonnancé de 45 nous intéressons à la
partie pénale c'est à dire aux jeunes
qu'ils ont commis des actes de
délinquance est effectivement le 13
septembre dernier le conseil des
ministres a adopté une ordonnance qui
vient créer un code de justice pénale
des mineurs
ce code il a deux objectifs très
simplement
c'est d'une part conformément à
l'ordonnancé de 45 de toujours donner la
primauté à l'éducatif sur le répressif
ainsi pris donc ce principe est
réaffirmé et au delà du principe je ne
partage pas l'avis de monsieur le député
bernalicis qui nous dit que on va aller
vers plus d'enfermement
il a raison dans le sens où nous avons
aujourd'hui trop de jeunes qui sont en
détention
il y à peu près 850 mineurs qui sont en
détention sont des jeunes qui sont pour
la plupart d'entre eux en détention
provisoire
et c'est donc la raison pour laquelle le
deuxième objectif de l'ordonance c'est
de permettre plus de rapidité dans le
prononcé de la culpabilité et ce sont
les procédures qui sont instaurées par
le code pénal que je porte et qui
devrait permettre qui devrait permettre
d'aller plus vite donc de donner une
réponse aux jeunes et aux victimes
également plus rapidement et enfin donc
je vais trop longue après le rajouter si
vous avez vous encore à préciser non non
je crois que je crois que c'est vraiment
ce double aspect que nous souhaitons
mettre en place et je dirais que moi
j'écris fin mois le ministère de la
justice a écrit l'aspect pénal et que
mon collègue adrien
key en charge des enfants est en train
de travailler sur l'aspect civil
c'est un problème parce que justement
les juges pour enfants et le ministère
de la justice
et vous-même aurait pu considérer ça
dans un texte global dans une logique
globale plutôt que d'opposer les deux
choses ou blessés par être désarmé
on ne pousse pas on formera un code de
la justice des mineurs
et il y aura le steve hill et le pénal
moi j'ai écrit au pénal mais si vous
vous mettez en place un code de la
justice pénale des mineurs c'est comme
ça que ça chez votre ordonnance reparti
sera le code de la justice et ben et
civile et donc on aura lançant toute la
pertinence de notre système c'est
d'avoir les deux mythes dans un seul et
même les mains du même du même juge qui
est en train de dire que c'est ce qu'on
en fait l'excédent vous n'êtes pas
convaincu zemmama convaincre ce soir on
va parler passer maintenant la parole à
jérôme bascher jérôme bascher voudrais
revenir avec vous sur les listes
communautariste oui vous avez reçu je
crois la semaine dernière bruno
retailleau et xavier bertrand dans sont
des amis politiques avec chez christophe
castaner et ils nous ont fait part de
leurs inquiétudes sur ses listes
communautaires qui ont dont on voit le
jour ici ou et là ce n'est plus
anecdotique mais ça devient un véritable
acte je peux le dire l'islam politique
et donc parce que c'est ce dont il
s'agit mais c'est donc bruno retailleau
vous a fait une proposition de texte
j'ai cosigné c'est une illusion je
l'avais l'autre sera déposée la semaine
prochaine je vous ai écouté la ministre
avant de rentrer sur ce plateau dogon
donc ça sera déposée la semaine
prochaine sur le bureau du sénat
et on aimerait savoir un peu au-delà des
1 tentation
dira oui c'est pas bien on entend du
président de la république le dire
devant les maires finalement qu'est ce
que vous faites
à part un quand tu es sur ce sujet alors
je ne crois pas que nous ne faisions
qu'un quand et nous agissons
vous savez très bien que la difficulté
de la proposition de loi de bruno
retailleau et de ce qu'ils ont cosigné
est une difficulté de nature
constitutionnelle
lui même d'ailleurs le reconnaissait il
me dit qu'il a pris des avis d'éminents
juristes et je le sais d'ailleurs j'ai
lu des articles en ce sens pour autant
la difficulté de nature conventionnelle
elle existe puisque vous le savez en
france la liberté du scrutin et donc la
liberté de se présenter aussi à une
élection ça fait vraiment partie des
droits les plus fondamentaux
alors je mesure néanmoins la difficulté
parce que je ne nie pas la réalité de ce
que vous dites mais il me semble que
d'une part il peut y avoir des
vérifications qui peuvent être opérés au
moment du dépôt des candidatures
regardez opérant non parce qu'on peut et
d'ailleurs nous allons faire un site et
les préfets avoir vraiment de la
vigilance sur ce sujet là et d'autre
part il me semble que le combat
politique est un combat qui mérite
également d'être mené sur sur sur les
valeurs que portent ces personnes ou
celles izco plus donc lors d'une
élection ce que vous y compris lors
d'une élection et y compris juste dans
ce que nous faisons
lorsque nous prenons par exemple les qr
les quartiers de lutte de reconquête
républicaine qui nous permettent
vraiment de déployer et vous le savez il
ya une quinzaine de quartiers où on
déploie énormément de forces de police
ou la police travaillait que la justice
de manière très resserré nous avons
réussi à fermer des commerces qui était
la devise avait dit cela parce que je me
souviens il ya quelques années aux
élections européennes des listes vous
proposer le vol you geek vous souvenez
peut-être d'ailleurs cela dit qu'il est
tous âges exactement mais tout ça ce
sont des dérives sectaires
amy devrait être traitée car cela était
payé avec de l'argent public oui mais
vous avez raison et je crois vraiment
quand on regarde les chiffres
freins des fermetures de différents
établissements y compris des fermetures
de cabinets de médecine prophétique qui
ont été fermés grâce au travail accompli
par la police et par la justice il me
semble nous sommes dans le combat
politique et cela je tiens beaucoup
donc si vous voulez que je dise il n'y a
pas besoin de loi je pense qu'il n'y a
pas besoin de loi il y a besoin d'une
circulaire d'ailleurs en forme oui je
sais je sais je respecte ce que vous
dites je ne suis pas d'accord
au nom du principe constitutionnel et de
la liberté d'expression que vous avez
dit faut mener le combat y compris
politiquement combat politique oui bien
sûr ugo bernalicis à propose cette fois
de la commission d' enquête
parlementaire que les insoumis veulent
déposer sur ça s'appelle les obstacles à
l'indépendance du pouvoir judiciaire et
s'impliquer mais ça doit être plus
simple que ça je pense qu'on voit à peu
près là je souhaite en venir et pas bien
parce que j'ai pas reçus encore être
nommé c mais vous la recevrez vous serez
convoqué pour être auditionné madame le
dj recevrait
ça va venir vous avez sans doute un
constat peut-être un peu partagé avec
moi puisque vous avez c'est l'article du
monde qui a été cité en première partie
entamée non pas une une réflexion vous
avez dit sur la question du statut des
magistrats
évidemment on a vu passer tous le
sondage sur la confiance dans la justice
qui est passe de 63 % en 2008 à 53 % en
septembre toutes les précautions qui est
à prendre avec les sondages évidemment
mais il ya surtout dans le détail est ce
que vous pensez que les juges sont
indépendants des intérêts économiques
seulement 51% le pense sont neutres et
impartiaux de leur jugement seulement 47
et sont indépendants du pouvoir
politique
seulement 45 donc je pense qu'il y avait
des progrès à faire et pu le constater
il ya de plus en plus de recours au juge
oui mais à ce paradoxe je souhaiterais
pouvoir dérouler mon propos aussi et
surtout la question et surtout la
question qui va avec
il y a me semble-t-il un problème de
séparation des pouvoirs
soula sous la vème république et il
suffit pas de dire tout le temps que les
magistrats sont indépendants pour qu'il
le soit j'en veux pour preuve la
question de la carte judiciaire avec les
juges d'instruction et je pense que mon
collègue sénateur en parlera après on
verra on le verra le le procureur de
partis de paris monsieur ed qui propose
de prolonger les gardes à vue le plus
possible pour les gilet jaune au mépris
du code de procédure pénale je suis pas
sûr que ce soit aussi en tout en toute
indépendance
et puis le dernier point et c'est là ma
question madame la ministre le procureur
l'ancien pos coeur de nice monsieur jean
michel prêtre dans la sphère geneviève
le guay qui a
dit avoir changé un peu la réalité pour
ne pas mettre en cause le chef de l'état
en tout cas ne pas perturber la
communication du chef de l'état emmanuel
macron est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quelle a été sa sanction
suite à cela alors moi je suis d'abord
je voudrais quand même préciser un
certain nombre de choses pour les
téléspectateurs
je vois bien j'ai lu ce sondage comme
vous que les français n'ont pas tout à
fait confiance dans la justice
pas suffisamment confiance dans la
justice mais ce qu'il reproche à la
justice c'est sa lenteur sont peu de
clarté et sa complexité ses eaux douces
et surtout ça non mais j'ai lu ce
sondage de manière précis qui est
d'ailleurs paru dans l'express de
manière précise donc les principaux
outils sont sur la lenteur la complexité
etc oui vous avez raison et monsieur
bernalicis a cité les chiffres il y a
des éléments sur l'indépendance mois sur
l'indépendance je voudrais dire deux
choses c'est que d'une part dans le
système français
il n'y a aucune instruction mais aucune
instruction donnée dans les affaires
individuelles
d'abord je pense que c'est absolument
aucune vous savez qu'un assaillant
emprunt série messieurs vernalis vos
prédécesseurs qui sort de la cour de
justice de la république monsieur roy
mais il n'a pas de justement sur ce
qu'il n'y a pas donné d'instructions il
a transmis une information à quelqu'un
d'autre
c'est ce qui c'est parce que c'est pour
ces raisons qu'il a été de condamner
c'est pas une instruction et jamais des
remontées d'informations comme tout ça
n'est pas une instruction monsieur vers
l'avant il faut pas tout mélanger si
vous voulez que nos concitoyens
comprennent jeudi que dans les affaires
individuelles
il y a aucune instruction donnée et je
sais bien que les politiques parfois
lorsqu'ils sont gênés aux entournures
dans certains aspects ont parfois
tendance ce n'est ce pas à nous le dire
que des instructions sont données
ce n'est pas le cas d'abord parce que ce
serait totalement contraire à l'état de
droit face à c'est un grand mot mais ça
ne nous viendrait même pas à l'esprit
même pas à l'esprit monsieur bernalicis
de décrocher mon téléphone pour dire à
un procureur didon dans cette affaire-là
vous voudrez bien
sur la terre longue et que je viens
d'évoquer ugo bernalicis le procureur de
la république a tenu des propos moi qui
nous stupéfier en disant ben oui j'ai
fait ça pour ne pas contredire je prends
le président de la république mais qui
sait donc qu'est-ce que vous les jours
en vo ce qui est peut-être c'est ce que
de banijay et ils ne sont plus en poste
2 et n'est plus en poste là où il est né
ce n'est pas une sanction madame la
ministre
il n'est plus en poste à nice il est
devenu avocat général est mieux payé
d'ailleurs dans et alors ça c'est pas un
problème mais non mais ou non ni on
s'imagine que quand on a fait une bêtise
on n'est pas mieux enfin j'ai maintenant
sous notre juridiction écouter
limitation les résolutions sont un sujet
alors si la sanction que de payer cher
signal lui par ailleurs que badens et
labrador
nous travaillons avec avis conforme du
conseil de la magistrature
je vous dis bien jamais une voiture
c'est pour ça que jérôme le conte c'est
super à la magistrature mais pas parler
d'une réforme là dessus j'ai parlé de la
question du statut des magistrats
jérôme baschet reviendrait à intervenir
sur vous l'avez évoqué l'histoire du des
projets de suppressions de postes juge
d'instruction oui on a été très surpris
vous avez été entendu par la commission
des lois du sénat sur le sujet ça
rejoint un peu la même question
l'un de vos conseillers a envoyé un mail
à un conseiller du premier ministre sur
les futurs les futures affectations de
magistrats suivant les résultats des
élections dans un certain nombre de
communes
voilà un ministre ma question est simple
vous avez estimé que c'était une
maladresse je crois que ce sont vos mots
qui vais me prononcer le mot d' erreur
une erreur très bien quelle a été la
sanction pour ce conseiller comme elle
était la sanction mais pour le procureur
il y à un moment les français ne
comprennent plus un ministre que parce
qu'on est un cabinet ministériel et je
sais très bien ce que c'est vous ne
soyez pas sanctionné je comprends que
vous n'ayez pas été mise au courant
c'est ce prêt ce que vous avez dit donc
quelle est la sanction vous avez
prononcé en disant il ya une erreur
majeure
une faute lourde un ami on est entre
nous non les personnes âgées c'est
maintenant entre nous je sais ce que je
dis des yeux d'anna pour vous aider
n'importe qui
la démocratie occidentale
le ministre de la justice garde des
sceaux aurait sauté dans les 24 heures
alors je voudrais vous dire quelque
chose monsieur le sénateur il n'est
absolument pas question je les dis
devant la commission d'enquêté dont vous
le savez parfaitement
il n'est absolument pas question qu'une
décision publique
a fortiori une décision concernant
l'organisation judiciaire soit prise sur
la barbe sur la base de critères
partisans
ça n'est pas possible ce n'est pas
envisageable ce n'est pas acceptable et
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas été auditionnés
ce n'est d'ailleurs pas ce qui se fait
et je crois que ça été envisagé il se
fait pas du tout et ça ne se fera jamais
ce qui est clair en revanche c'est que
dans l'évolution de notre organisation
judiciaire qui passe vous le savez au
1er janvier prochain par le regroupement
des tribunaux quant à 100 sur le pré
ménages judiciaire ça se traduire
également par des projets de
spécialisation de contention entre jury
pulsions et d'ailleurs je crois savoir
que dans votre département il ya des
problèmes d fait normal voilà ça peut
également et votre sens de ma question
non non je vous souhaite des sanctions
j'ai eu l'occasion de préciser que
l'ensemble de ces décisions notamment
sur les spécialisations sur les
éventuels
évolution des juges d'instruction se
ferait selon des critères clairs et
transparents après avis des conseils de
juridictions où siègent les élus les
avocats etc et que tout cela se ferait
dans leurs rangs sont revenir à la
question a confié je réagis c'est aussi
la sanction est ce que le conseiller à
l'origine de la note susdite a été
draguée alors très clairement il est
important quand on travaille dans un
cabinet depuis deux ans et demi avec des
gens qui travaillent vous le savez
énormément puisque nous sommes 10 la
première fois que nous sommes dix dans
un cabinet moi je fais lire on y pose sa
volée je fais confiance à mon cabinet et
pesant une erreur une erreur une erreur
mérite de ce niveau m d'être une erreur
de secondes a été suivie dans des
réseaux qu'un effet elle n'a été suivie
d'aucune est ce que ce qu'il était
sanctionné mais non il ya eu madame la
ministre sur ce sujet lui c'est
différent c'est différent vous parlez
alors il ya eu une fuite sur une erreur
majeure et c'est pour ça que vous
dites-vous de sortie n'est pas ça me
rappelle furieusement nord d'affaires
benalla kings dans laquelle c'est parce
que j'ai depuis qu'il ya eu une
sélection vous cherchez à tout mélanger
non je les dis clairement chez congrès
une erreur il ya une sanction confiance
dans mon cabinet je le redis ici
clairement et je maintiens cette
confiance en revanche sur le fond de la
faire je suis intransigeante les
décisions concernant la justice comme
les décisions publiques ne se font
absolument pas sur des critères
partisans
voilà maintenant ugo bernalicis vous
voyez vous vouliez parler de la
situation dans les prisons
oui oui mais c'est quand même inquiétant
que à chaque fois la défense de madame
la ministre je le dis je au mépris des
faits quoi
d'accord mais non au mépris des cas
vous verra qu'on veut supprimer les
juges d'instruction après les élections
municipales donc mais il sera trop tard
et surveiller la carte des suppressions
mais tout le monde la surveille déjà je
me dis qu'il doit y avoir des tas de
remontée aurait du capitany prison de la
garde des sceaux sur le sujet oui bon
alors non mes chats persans je
m'aperçois que vous n'avez aucun fait
précis à me citer parce qu'il n'y en à
partie il ya un mail qui est très précis
pas de ça jeudi dans une nouvelle ère
nous qu'avons nous qu'à vous
qu'avez-vous à montrer qui relève de
critères partisans rien parce que rien
ne relève de critères partie via la
question sur les prisons au bernalicis
parce que c'est un domaine que vous
connaissez bien
par ailleurs oui mais il connaît bien la
justice en général en général
la prison on a une augmentation encore
pour 2020 de 5 55% des crédits elle
absorbe l'essentiel du budget de la
justice puisqu'on a que 0 32 %
d'augmentation des crédits sur la
justice judiciaire pour pour 2020 est ce
que vous pensez
madame la ministre que construire des
prisons c'est véritablement la priorité
quand on voit la faiblesse des moyens
qui sont mis sur le milieu ouvert j'en
veux pour preuve par exemple placement à
l'extérieur souvenez vous je vous ai
interrogé sur le sujet en commission le
placement extra pour ceux qui nous
regardent ces des mesures alternatives à
l'incarcération style est brassée
l'électro dit alors non cdc des mesures
beaucoup plus resserré où il ya un
encadrement de la personne sous main de
justice
il ya plusieurs dispositifs ça peut être
la ferme de moyens briquet dispositif
emblématique où vous faites de la
culture maraîchère pendant six mois un
an un an et demi à quoi ça sert budget
là sont gelés sur les mêmes ils n'ont
pas plus 58 5 points 55 % d'augmentation
au sein même de l'admiration entre six
nations est-ce que vous ne trouvez pas
qu'on est en train de faire un peu
n'importe quoi
en mettant tous les moyens sur la
construction de places de prison alors
même qu'on est en difficulté pour
recruter des surveillants et qu'il
manque de moyens sur sur le milieu
ouvert sans compter que l'objectif à la
fin ça reste quand même la prévention de
la récidive
d'accord je sais bien qu'ils ont c'est
bien vous et moi que l'objectif c'est la
prévention de la récidive et
qu'aujourd'hui là car ces rations c'est
pas le meilleur taux de prévention de la
sonatt heures de la réponse si ce jeu
vous savez très bien que je partage le
fond de votre analyse pas ses résultats
vous savez très bien que je souhaite
clairement qu' on puisse prononcer des
sanctions qui soit adaptée pour les
personnes qui ont commis des infractions
ou des crimes des sanctions adaptées
parmi ces sanctions adaptées il y à la
prison mais il ya aussi d'autres
sanctions vous citiez donc à partir de
là toute la loi qui a été votée par vous
même en mars enfin parler par le
parlement en mars 2019
c'est une loi qui vise à une meilleure
adaptation des sanctions à la peine des
sanctions aux infractions c'est la base
de ce que nous faisons c'est la base
pour autant
et je me permettez moi de vous signaler
que les premiers résultats
les premiers résultats montrent une
inflexion de la courbe des des tenues
très légères liés à aux premières
mesures que nous avons prises pour
autant nous avons une surpopulation
carcérale nous avons vous le savez 70
mille détenus 60000 places de prison
donc d'accord donc il faut forcément
créer des places nouvelles mais ces
places nouvelles communes créent eux
c'est peut-être c'est ce que je vous ai
je ne dis pas sortir des gens de prison
jeudi trouvaient des peines adaptées la
conséquence c'est de la surpopulation
carcérale devrait diminuer un peu pour
autant on aura toujours beaucoup de gens
en prison il faut les traiter là aussi
par un parcours de peines adaptées juste
se termine là les places de prison que
nous créons sont des places qui doivent
permettre une meilleure réinsertion
sociale lorsque nous créons quelque
chose vous dites ça pourrait permettre
de réduire la population carcérale est
ce qu'il ya un objectif chiffré quelque
chose des vêtements neufs châtier les
places de prison créée parce que vous
êtes gérant a donc raison objective
c'est mon objectif c'est d'avoir ces
peines adaptées
autrement dit c'est pas de dire tout le
monde va emprise les badges actifs
chiffrer ce jeudi non je on a une étude
d'impact qui est de que les députés
connaît ce qui devrait être une
diminution de 8000 personnes en
détention
mais ce jeune saint denis des 8000
déjà parce que la loi est pas
entièrement entre en application il n'y
a que quelques mesures nous on attend
beaucoup de moi dans les décrets nous
créons les 15 me pour les journaux je
suis bernalicis vous mélangez tout
l'hexagone a fini c'est là parce que
disent ils alors pourquoi vous pourquoi
vous couper la parole pour dire quelque
chose qui n'a rien à voir avec ce dont
nous parlons c'est tout de même
excellent parce que le lycée votre jeu
en disant que nous essayons de
construire des places de prison qui
permettent un parcours de peine qui
réellement permettent l'insertion et
parmi les places de prison que nous
créons sur les 15000 que nous devons
créer
nous allons d'abord ouvrir des
structures d'accompagnement vers la
sortie c'est à dire des structures qui
prennent en charge les détenus en fin de
peine pour leur apporter tous les
éléments
en matière d'emploi de logement de santé
pour qu'ils puissent se réinsérer plie
pas si facilement jérôme bascher une
dernière question concernant la réforme
constitutionnelle ça c'était le thème
qui vous intéressent bah oui mais c'est
un thème qui intéresse c'est bien la
ministre connaît par coeur la
constitution et son passé plaide pour
elle mais le gouvernement avait promis
une réforme de la constitution
aujourd'hui elle est repoussée signé et
depuis tout à l'heure je vous entends
dire ce n'est pas prévu par la
constitution ce est inconstitutionnelle
et donc il n'y a pas de solution
pourquoi ne remettez vous pas sur la
table la réforme constitutionnelle avec
ses vrais sujets bada la mise avec ses
vrais sujets et non pas les sous sujets
comme le président de la république
avait fait dans sa campagne électorale
alors que les vrais sujets qui sont la
laïcité par exemple qui sont les listes
donc communautariste qui sont les sujets
que j'ai évoquées précédemment
aujourd'hui et on en parle plus donc
quand est-ce que vous remettez un vrai
projet concessionnels sur la table ces
deux sénateurs le projet il est sur la
table puisqu'il a été adopté en conseil
des ministres donc sans ambages étape
d'une problème serait je retiens que le
première historique comme sous sujet les
éléments qui s'attache à la
différenciation territoriale j'avais cru
comprendre que vos collègues sénateurs à
cela voyez bien bungle sous sujet que
serait la différenciation territoriale
la démocratie participative
l'indépendance de la justice
non seulement son indépendance au dg
d'accor vous le savez je sais puisque je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure
donc non je crois que les thèmes qui
sont dans la révision constitutionnelle
sont des thèmes qui sont des sujets
solide et sur lesquelles il ya des
boissons diageo la montée comme vous
l'avez démontré voulait pas que si le
document si ce projet n'est pas encore
soumis à débat c'est parce que nous
avons beaucoup travaillé avec le sénat
que nous étions sur un ou presque
accor je crois pouvoir le dire en
matière de réformes constitutionnelles
stricto sensu mais comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même au sénat le président larcher
l'avait dit il faut quelque chose de
global
il y avait l'idée des accords le me
rends sur les lois organiques
c'est à dire vu le nombre de sénateurs
les mêmes et c'est donc là dessus nous
sommes à leur mercie jérôme bascher
d'être venu sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques et d'avoir mené le débat avec
la mise de la justice est presque aussi
chaud qu'à l'international au sénat mais
j'ai pas dis merci beaucoup en tout cas
devenue sur ce plateau
nicole belloubet on va accueillir
maintenant yves thréard du figaro qui va
vous mettre à la question aussi
[Musique]
bonsoir oui j'aime avoir consorts la
ministre est ce que vous êtes
autoritaire oui vous vous laissez pas
marcher sur les pieds si vous si je puis
me permettre face un ministre de la
république
mais vous avez une autorité naturelle
qui fait que c'est difficile de pouvoir
vous piéger alors je cherche un léger
jeu je crois que ce que je dis c'est
vrai il ya un sujet que vous n'avez pas
évoqué et qui est quand même le sujet
principal sur lequel la justice est très
critiqué et qui explique peut-être le
mauvais sondages que la justice reçoit
aujourd'hui qui est un sondage qui
montre que la justice finalement et le
moins aimé des services publics dans
notre pays quasiment c'est l'exécution
des peines
pourquoi les peines en france sont mal
exécutés ou pas exécutée ça se compte en
dizaine de milliers alors je n'ai pas
évoqué ce sujet parce que bon ça ne
s'est pas pressé à prêter je sors oui je
sais pas si c'est la raison pour
laquelle les français aiment peu la
justice enfin peu non je ne sais pas
peut mais pour lesquels il ya cette
interrogation sur la justice subtile par
parenthèse c'est vraiment mon premier
souci vraiment notamment sur l'exécution
des peines sur la question des délais
sur la question de la complexité bien je
reviens à votre question sur l'exécution
des peines
je crois que vous avez raison c'est à
dire que une des difficultés qui a été
constatée qui a été la base la réflexion
de la loi du 23 mars 2010neuf c'est
précisément que les français ne pouvais
pas croire dans les peines puisque on
prononce un an et demi de prison et que
jamais la personne ne va en détention
puisque parce qu'il ya une
transformation de la peine un
aménagement de certaines qui sont et
c'est précisément ce que nous avons
voulu faire dans la loi de réforme pour
la justice nous avons dit nous avons dit
au magistrat a b g un objectif clair
c'est que j'avais quand mais je ne sais
pas si chiffres et pardonnez moi j'ai un
objectif clair c'est que nous avons
juste dit deux choses quand la prison
peut trouver quand il peut y avoir une
autre réponse l'horizon il faut le faire
mais quand une peine de prison est
prononcée pour un an il faut qu'elle
soit exécutée et donc la loi a changé on
pense à 100%
bien sûr c'est la promesse du président
de la république sont élancés aura lieu
donc quelqu'un qui sera condamné à un
nom ira en détention d'accord alors il
ya une grande réforme on en a parlé un
petit peu la réforme des retraites vous
allez voir le premier ministre dimanche
j'espère pour vous allez le voir avant
vous êtes mal ce matin vous êtes mal à
l'aise là quand même
c'est mal parti on verra le gouvernement
non je crois que le gouvernement s'ils
voulaient ce que ce que ce qu'a voulu le
président de la république et le premier
ministre je crois c'est garder un
système par répartition est un système
qui soit universelle vous êtes sûr que
cette réforme sera votée d'ici à la fin
du quinquennat
écoutez moi je suis sur un bon mois j'en
suis sûr et si ça bloque
à partir du 5 décembre et qu'on y va
nous sommes dans une attitude je parle
pour le gouverneur dans une attitude
ouverte où nous disons il faut que cette
réforme se fasse parce que sinon nous
courons à la catastrophe
cette réforme pour qu'elle ait lieu nous
proposons je ne crois en tout cas un
système universel par répartition et
plus juste moi elle me convient
dans ce conte en dedans ce qu'on a
établi aujourd'hui durant une heure et
s'est mal terminée parce qu'il ya des
choses qui ne sont pas arbitrées
c'était précisément ça on a un rapport
du cor qui nous dit mme alimentation des
retraites joue merci beaucoup
on a un rapport du cor qui nous dit en
2025 il y aura entre 7 et 17 milliards
de déficits ou on ne peut pas construire
un système de retraite sur la base d'un
système qui serait pas équilibré
financièrement donc il y a plusieurs
hypothèses ces hypothèses elles ont été
évoqués par le premier ministre soit on
diminue les pensions nous n'en est pas
question
soit on augmente les cotisations
accidents n'est pas question pour nous
ce qu'on veut c'est précisément
valoriser le travail donc il faut jouer
sur la question du soin de la durée de
cotisation soit d'un âge pivot soit de
la clause du petit fils il y a plus et
ça c'est en discussion et c'est de cela
dont nous allons parler et c'est simple
ça vous irait ce qui est plutôt une
frappe du bien
de reporter l'âge de départ à la
retraite écoutez moi je considère qu'à
partir du moment où le futur parti
socialiste a pas très longtemps il n'y a
pas très longtemps et j'en suis fier
elle avait raison
j'ai le note donc moi le président de la
république a dit on pourra toujours
partir à la retraite à l'âge de 62 ans
donc ça ça ressemble âge de départ à la
retraite après je sais pas si c'est au
critt moi je ne sais pas si hypocrite
que de dire après tout jusqu'à 63 64 65
ans vous pouvez partir à la retraite et
ça il ya plusieurs solutions à saissac
juste un mot c'est ça qui est en cours
de concertation va regarder si vous êtes
tous d'accord à l'intérieur du
gouvernement sur cette réforme
on en débat et un sentiment quand même
moi je crois qu'on sera tous ept j'ai
regardé un petit peu et j'ai lu ce que
disaient les ministres qui viennent
plutôt de la droite darmana le maire il
sait pas tout à fait la même chose que
vous ils sont plus jusqu'au boutiste il
faut aller plus loin
mais qu'est ce qu'ils disent qu'est ce
qu'ils disent est devant eux ils sont
pas contre le report de l'âge de la de
l'âge de départ à la retraite si vous
laissez des modalités différentes pour
aboutir à un même résultat
alors eux ils ont constitué un petit
groupe là le corps du darmanin ils
viennent de la droite
et vous pourquoi vous n'arrivez pas
constituer un petit groupe de gauche là
mais cher monsieur thréard vous ne savez
pas ce que je vais faire en vous
quittant à savater est ce que vous
faites a dit d avec des zones
sérieusement très sérieusement non j'ai
un dîner avec mes collègues ministres
régaliens
ils sont pas tous de gauche donc si
monsieur castaner ya ma gauche non sur
le drian c'est un dîner avec mes
collègues régalien et c'est avec grand
plaisir que j'ai toujours de la gauche
effectivement qui sauf cas c'est à dire
je règle aurions vous le dis si j'arrive
dans un club de gauche dont celle il
n'existe pas un club il existait
rencontre amicale qui peuvent parfois
prendre des formes différentes
une question sur laquelle vous êtes
prononcer vous l'avez dit vous êtes
contre les comptes à les quotas sur
l'immigration j'ai pas dit que j'étais
contre
il faut que les d'ailleurs de ceux
conduits là je n'ai mais alors vraiment
pas une feuille de papier à cigarette
entre la position du premier ministre
est la mienne je dis simplement que dans
les expériences précédentes quand on a
des quotas trop rigide du genre il nous
faut 2200 un plombier
ça ne marche pas mais en revanche et le
prémice à utiliser le terme lui-même il
dit mais on peut très bien dans les
métiers en tension établir des
fourchettes et ça ça me semble tout à
fait normal c'est ça que j'ai voulu dire
c'est cinq seulement que j'ai voulu un
autre sujet pour faire vite le
référendum d initiative partagée sur
notamment et on adp aéroports de paris
donc on va arriver peut-être d'ici à la
fin de l'année un million de signataires
est ce que vous seriez pour que
finalement et bien ce référendum ait
lieu
moi je sais que le parlement vient s'est
prononcé je trouve très curieux que on
engage une procédure de référendum
d'initiative partagée
à peine le parlement s'est il prononcé
et donc ça moi ça me gêne dans sa
conception c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs dans la révision
constitutionnelle dont vous parliez tout
à l'heure nous avons mis des
dispositions à la fois pour faciliter se
répartir d'un million de fumer en même
temps pour faire en sorte biomill qui du
reste ne serait pas le moment là sur adp
d'abord je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive aux
quatre millions et demi mais il a mis
lyon juste oui mais non je trouve
nettement que la difficulté là c'est
parce que le parlement venait juste de
se prononcer et que je trouve que on ne
peut pas à la fois on peut pas jouer la
démocratie participative contre la
démocratie représentative est donc là ça
n'allait pas vous êtes pour la
privatisation de la dp d'aéroports de
paris
je trouve que le ministre de l'économie
tel qu'il a proposé une évolution de la
dp c'est à dire avec une privatisation
encadré c'est tout à fait possible dans
la mesure où les fonctions de service
public reste préservée yves sur l'ovi
municipal
vous avez vous n'avez pas toulouse
donc parce que vous avez été conseillère
municipale à toulouse a été premier
adjoint
le premier adjoint mieux que ça encore
mais ça vous ça vous dit rien leur
tournée non jeu
je vous empêcherait pas d'être ministre
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises et quelles que soient
les fonctions je trouve qu'on peut
difficilement être et avoir été
j'ai été très investis à toulouse et sur
la région midi pyrénées c'est une
période de ma vie qui est terminée j'ai
été très heureuse d'être d'avoir cet
investissement local ça me donne je
crois une compréhension de territoire
président non je peux dissone non donc
je vous pose la question
non je pense que on peut pas ou ne peut
pas dire mais celui-là y manque sa revue
qui avait dit même à un moment c'est
ringard d'avoir été député pour le
président de la république
non mais c'est pas ringard non plus
heureusement cette valise valeur ce qui
pour vous était importante
j'ai personnellement capital d'accor qui
habitent tous terrifiés
alors toute dernière question pas c'est
très simple 2022 il ya des sondages qui
circulent ou n'y est pas pas différente
marine le pen emmanuel macron 55% pour
emmanuel macron 45% par marine le pen
pour marine le pen
si le cas de figure se présente ça veut
dire que ça se rapproche le l'écart est
bien est de moins en moins important
ça vous inquiète pas ça ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure moi je crois pas
soit l'échec des politiques mais non
mais c'est pas le chef politique je
crois à l'action politique
les premiers résultats
non alors c'est partant non je ne suis
pas inquiète je suis vigilante c'est
comme sur les listes communautarisme
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure je ne
suis pas inquiète je suis vigilante et
moi je crois à l'action politique
les premiers résultats de l'action
conduite par le gouvernement se font
clairement sentir vous voyez sur le
chômage vous voyait sur plein d'autres
éléments sûrs et donc je crois qu'il y à
des résultats positifs et moi je suis
certaine que le président de la
république engrangera ces résultats et
pourra se représenter
oui si vous le souhaitez oui clairement
merci merci nicole belloubet c'est la
fin merci yves merci ça sert votre
audition publique
n'oubliez pas vous pouvez retrouver
cette émission sur figaro live et sur
les comptes twitter de lcp assemblée
nationale et public sénat
bonne semaine merci et à lundi prochain
19 heures en direct
[Musique]